where does the
trans part of this all fit in because i
remember years ago
when people would say when i when
everyone started saying the lgbt
community i remember thinking i have no
more insight into the t part of this
than a straight cisgendered heterosexual
male would you know what i mean i i just
i don't i i maybe i have
somehow slightly a little more inherent
empathy by being an outsider at some
level but i don't have any more
knowledge of it
and now it seems like the trans issue
has almost superseded all of the other
issues at least in the last year i mean
everywhere
yeah everywhere you go there's you know
every time i open the twitter search bar
it's another trans story or
someone's being fired for this joke or
that
what do you think happened there that
catapulted this so quickly and what are
the issues around it that we're kind of
afraid to talk about right now
it's a really complicated fraud topic
well i think
i think like the legitimate
issue about trans is there are people
who
are trans or feel trans and they want
their rights respected and that's
totally legitimate and and good for them
and raising awareness about that is fine
there's a much larger group of people
who i think are using
trans issues as a kind of wedge to
destroy
the gender binary or to kind of muddy
the waters
or basically as a weapon to beat up
evolutionary psychology
or evolutionary biology to say there's
no such thing as
sex really there's no such thing as
biological sex or sex is totally
dissociated from gender etcetera so when
someone says that the next time someone
says that on twitter what's the answer
that the person watching this should
give that
maybe twitter's not the best moment for
it i mean
male and female are evolved strategies
that exist because over thousands of
generations
they were like the paths to
successful reproduction um if you're not
clearly male and functioning as a male
or you're not clearly female and
functioning as a female
you're you're a genetic dead end so
selection
hammers against any ambiguity
there so it's not surprising that the
vast majority of humans alive today
clearly identify as one sex or the other
um
that doesn't mean everyone should it
doesn't have any kind of moral
implications about that but just
descriptively
it means there is a gender binary and it
evolved
for good reasons and everyone who
teaches biology hopefully
knows this and it shouldn't be that
controversial right now if we want to
like genetically engineer people and use
crispr and whatever to
destroy the gender binary for the 22nd
and 23rd centuries
we could do that we could talk about
that um
i don't have any particular attachment
to the kind of male female dichotomy
ethically but i think descriptively it's
really important
to kind of accept it and and to go it's
here
it's valuable to understand and we
shouldn't necessarily try to
pretend it out of existence um or
pretend that
we're doing it in the name of trans
rights right
you can have trans rights without saying
there's no such thing as sex so this
gets to the heart of what i think
is really happening in this country
right now which is everything has become
politicized to the point
that the experts in the field seem
afraid to talk about these issues
you right now are taking a risk by
talking about these
issues yeah are you seeing this across
the board
are you seeing this amongst colleagues
of fear to talk about these things
yeah absolutely now the vast majority of
people like at my university
don't really touch upon anything that's
particularly politicized
right they're just teaching civil
engineering or law or
immunology or whatever and most of that
isn't
really politicized yet however
yet is the key word yeah right right
okay
i mean you get a little bit bit about
what's the gender representation in
certain fields but in my department in
psychology
you do get almost everything having a
kind of political edge
and i have colleagues who are frightened
to teach certain classes
like i teach psychology of human
sexuality and i'm pretty
upfront and outspoken about what i cover
and and what my view is
but a lot of my colleagues will not
touch it with a barge pool
because there's so much risk that
students will
just get upset about one little thing
you say yeah and complain to a dean
and then you'll get called into the
office and um
so what would be that type of thing
beyond what you just said about
the need and the evidence of gender
differences what are the other type of
things that just talking about
are scaring the academics it's very
awkward to talk about sex differences
in any mental traits or motivations or
preferences
it's hard to talk about sexual coercion
rape date rape
harassment stalking etc that must be an
incredibly difficult one at college yeah
yeah um it's hard to talk about
um aggression in general either
between individuals or between groups
and how that relates to sexuality
like why hunter-gatherer tribes go to
war
right it's not typically about land or
food it's about women
and that doesn't fit the kind of marxist
picture of
prehistoric warfare right
and then if you talk about stuff like um
pregnancy child care parenting
are you being you know overly
pronatalist
and sort of family values for talking
about that stuff
is that alienating to certain students
who might be
homosexual or infertile or or
adopted kids or whatever um but
it's so interesting because i obviously
hear these types of stories from
academics all the time not only in here
but
but online and people email me all the
time and it's like god
we've failed i mean the universities
really have failed at that point
like if you're afraid to talk about
child rearing because that might upset a
gay person
yeah jesus i mean what's left
at that point it's so frustrating and it
means
i feel bad for the students but i also
feel bad for the parents who are often
footing the tuition bill
because the parents have faith that if i
send my kid
to a state university and i pay tens of
thousands in tuition
and they take a course on topic x like
human sexuality
that they're going to get professors who
are willing to profess
to say what they really think and often
they're not getting that
so there's a kind of bait and switch
where universities are pretending to be
these bastions of free speech and
inquiry and and
honesty and in fact
everyone's kind of running scared and
these kids are not getting our best
insights
they're paying the money but we're not
delivering the service
how much of an infection not just in the
classroom do you see this as
but i think correctly vermont i think
you've written around 110 published
papers is that right
did i get the exact number right is it
100 more or less more or less you lose
count
at some point um i'm sure you're well
aware of the peter pagozi and
sokol hoax that it's not just what's
happening in the classroom that's
causing the chaos but it
actually may be what's happening before
that related to all of these papers
that certain disciplines basically have
i don't think i'm overestimating they
almost have no standards yeah at this
point
that that has got to be just incredibly
frustrating for someone that actually
has published
some things legitimately it's kind of
frustrating but
i can see you don't get frustrated
easily but um like it doesn't bug me as
much as
maybe it bugs some other people partly
because i spent a lot of my
undergraduate
um years taking courses on
critical theory and i read a lot of
derry dawn foucault and leotard and all
those french dudes and
one reason i loved those courses is it
was so
easy to get an a by writing a kind of
[ __ ] paper using the right terms
and using sufficiently obscure syntax
right that so i know that game
god that's real very well it's really
real yeah
and it's great fun i understand the
appeal of that stuff
it's just i can't imagine spending my
adult life doing nothing but that
and that's what's happening in a lot of
the humanities
so it like if if those folks want to do
that
and and get paid typically not a very
good salary
to do that i don't it doesn't really
viscerally offend me
the only danger is is when they
turn into activists and they give people
like me grief
based on not understanding what i do
yeah well i would imagine a lot of it
just then leaks into your classroom
and then and all bets are off
it's weird it doesn't actually leak in
like when i teach human sexuality right
the kids have a sort of vague um
political correctness that they've
absorbed mostly in k-12 public school i
think
but if you actually ask them have you
had
any courses on gender feminism no
have you heard of any of these leading
figures from
critical theory or history of feminism
or
even history of gay rights they know
nothing about
so it's not like they've been
indoctrinated at least not in
big state schools but they've kind of
soaked up some stuff from high school
i think that influences how they
interpret everything so as two guys
wearing might i say
very nice shirts right now a shiny
purple shirt and a shiny blue shirt
let's talk about evolutionary aesthetics
cool
people don't talk about aesthetics yeah
that much but you think that sort of the
things we're looking at
in the west are maybe not as exciting as
they should be and that there's a
problem there is that
fair to say yeah i've been really into
art
for a long time and i think art and
beauty are important um
particularly the places people live
and work and i think as humans we kind
of deserve
the best from artists interior designers
stylists whatever architects that
make our lives as pleasant as possible
and i think basically ever since about
1910 art and architecture has failed
and has not done a very good job of
delivering
visual environments that are actually
humane
and appealing and enjoyable and that
kind of promote
mental and physical health what happened
around 19 days modernism man
um if you look at
the way domestic architecture worked up
until about that period
it was all sort of human scale and arts
and crafts and
um there are places you'd want to live
where you didn't have to be
educated into a particular elite
notion of what a house should be in
order to appreciate it
right and then you get the bauhaus
international modernism
white structures crisp hard lines
um bad acoustics
and suddenly that becomes the fashion
right
that becomes what people think are is
the future
and nobody likes it yeah but it's kind
of imposed
top down by the elite you must
live like this like it or not is is that
top-down from the leader is that just
that often those things are just easier
to build
probably and cheaper to build or maybe
that's the same thing actually
well the irony is like you could have
taken
cheap easy to build reinforced concrete
structures
and built a lot of awesome cheap houses
that were okay
or you could do the traditional route
but instead what you get is
every house must be distinct and must
have its own shape
and there can't be any
standardization so the houses end up
being expensive
and experimental and hard to maintain
and they leak and
everyone's miserable so they're not
really serving the needs of the
the people at large they're just
great for architect egos yeah it's
interesting because i just spent
a couple months bouncing through a lot
of different countries in europe and
you know especially on most of these
countries because the history goes back
so far
you see incredible architecture you see
even you know i
see chairs that were 150 years old and
like the woodwork that would go into it
and the craftsmanship
and it was like i don't think we could
do this today or if we could do it today
this would have caught this chair would
be in our dollars it would be like a
thousand five hundred dollar chair where
back then you know this is what a guy
did it took him a couple days
and he could sell it and earn a wage and
it's like we've just the economics of
everything have gotten out of whack
yeah and like nice table here and
this slash probably this is the new
thing you slide it on the table right
when you walked in so i know you mean it
yeah
um i've made a few pieces of furniture
in my day and that
that's pretty cool but yeah with the
visual art in particular
um the economics mean like
abstract painting just is so much faster
to do than representational painting
right if you're a young aspiring artist
and you want a career and you want to
give your
gallery a certain flow of work that they
can sell
it's a lot harder to do that if you're
doing representational paintings that
take
100 300 hours than an abstract work that
takes
a tenth of that so the economic
pressures are also
in that direction yeah um
but people have um
kind of voted with their feet and like
they don't like
elite abstract art they don't like
conceptual
art um but it is like the word the right
word there or they just don't
they just don't know or it's
conditioning or it's
that we all like to like what everybody
else likes
sort of thing i think everybody knows
that they're kind of supposed to enjoy
going to
like while we're visiting this city we
should go to the contemporary art museum
and then get there
and there's a bunch of terrible video
art and there's a bunch of
very puzzling conceptual art and they
read the little
descriptions on the walls and they go
this makes no sense because it's written
by an art curator for other art curators
and it's all completely alienating and
that's
that's sad because it means they're
being told this is the highest
expression of your culture
but it's completely inaccessible to you
so what uh what do you look at that
gives you some excitement or can still
sort of
renew your spirit let's say well there
is a movement of kind of
neo-traditionalism
in in art where there's there's certain
places like new york academy of arts
that are actually teaching students how
to draw and paint and sculpt and
and do the sort of traditional
skills that people associate with art
it's just a little hard to get a
foothold in the like the new york or
london gallery system
if that's the kind of work that you do
um
but my hope is that like the bay area
billionaires will start collecting that
stuff
i think the chinese art market is has
got a real thirst for
good representational art and i think
that's going to start
to dominate the art world pretty soon so
what's the evolutionary need
for good art i mean what's the
psychological i mean i know
you're okay there's an expression of
something that can't quite be
said but what's like the the driving
force behind that
so yeah on the one hand there's why do
we bother to make art
on the other hand why why do we like
certain kinds of art
and there's been a lot more research on
why do we like certain kinds of patterns
and colors and forms and compositions
and whatever
but there's no sort of
unified theory of aesthetics
in fact i would say there's more good
stuff published on that topic between
about
1870 and 1920 than since
because that's when people were sort of
very inspired by darwin
evolutionary aesthetics was a field
there were dozens of books published on
it
and then modernism came and everyone
forgot all that
how could this be connected to the
earlier topic which is sexuality so for
example my
gay male friends generally speaking
have a much better eye for art or for
style
or for fashion yeah you know you could
get away in that crew you know what i
mean like you got a nice jacket on you
got a nice shirt like that
you know like i mean that is a
compliment like where
again just broadly speaking it's like my
straight guy
friends all kind of wear big shirts and
they don't know exactly how to do their
hair
and they're you know so there's some
connection between sexuality
and artistic vision
i think that's absolutely true and it's
not what you would
predict from first principles it's
really weird if you look around at other
species
the males are typically much more
ornamented than the females
they have the the amazing plumage and
they do the incredible
songs and dances and the females are
usually kind of drab and
and not that aesthetic
the power birds that make these
incredible kind of installation works
that's all the males then you get to
humans
or at least american males american
straight males
and it's like can't you even find
clothes that fit
like colors it's the big shirt and
like what is up with your house
you know and when i did this why jordan
peterson saw two million copies to tell
people to clean their room
yeah so i have no
idea why gay men have better taste than
straight men
i think that's a fascinating there's
some there has to be
something going on there um
but i think men can level up obviously
because like british and european men
aren't as hopeless if you grow up a
young man in italy
you kind of absorb some ideas about
style
and even the british kind of aristocrats
landed gentry class
have a certain look that
it's a bit traditionalist but at least
there's taste i don't know if this is
going to quite make sense but were we
almost getting there
say 10 years ago with the rise of the
metrosexual
and then it sort of crashed because i
guess
maybe it relates back to what you said
at the beginning about where we are more
puritan
so there was this idea there was this
like mocking of them like ah they're
just gay but don't want to admit it or
something like that
and that whole thing seemed to crash
like there was this little brief window
where straight
guys were like dressing better or yeah
had cooler haircuts or something
something there
well even five years ago when i lived in
new york for a little bit and
i hung out uh hung out a lot in brooklyn
there was sort of that was peak hipster
in brooklyn and the guys there the
straight guys put a lot of effort into
grooming and haircuts and authentic
style and
this or that is in fashion and i thought
this is really cool this is like a
europeanization
of male taste and culture
but it was also very masculine it wasn't
sort of like late 70s disco culture
or early 90s rave culture or
or burning man culture it was sort of
more old-school masculine
old school like i want to go to a proper
barber and get a proper haircut
and like it's all flannel and boots and
whatever
and i love that stuff um but i think it
kind of had its moment
and evaporated i don't know i think in
that case they just priced themselves
out of the market in brooklyn
probably something yeah yeah yeah or
they just got
all too busy on twitter well that it
always comes back to that
let's talk a little bit about mate
selection regardless
of your sexuality there seems to be this
new thing right now where if you're not
open to dating
absolutely anyone under any
circumstances no matter how they look or
how they take care of themselves or
whether they brush their teeth
or whether they have a penis or a vagina
or any combination of anything
that if you aren't just open to anything
there's a pretty loud and growing voice
out there that is trying to frame
everyone as a as a bigot
which is the reverse of what choosing a
mate really has been about
it's insane i mean for 500 all right i
got you i got emotional
miller there we go 500 million years
right our vertebrate ancestors have been
choosing the mates
selectively because that is the highest
stakes
decision any organism makes is who do i
recombine my genes with
right and so all the way through the
chordates and the vertebrates and the
mammals and the primates
you get particularly females being
choosy
about you know who they breed with who
sires their kids
but then as soon as humans start doing
pair bonds
million two million years ago and the
males start investing more in offspring
start forming longer-term relationships
then we also have incentives to be
choosy
about our female mates
and so this is the one domain where if
you have
even a shred of libertarian in you
or you respect freedom of association at
all or you think it's okay to care
who you spend your life with and like
what kind of children you you create
then mate choice should be a kind of
domain of freedom
right like this is a good place to be
prejudiced so to speak right yeah like
you should have some uh you should just
be discriminating yeah have judgment um
criminating taste
and you can always be open to the idea
that maybe the current
set of criteria that i have maybe could
be nudged or improved or tweaked or
maybe i'm
subject to certain stereotypes and maybe
i could overcome those
true of course people tend to get better
at mate choice in their 30s than in
their teens
but for someone to start lecturing you
politically like you shouldn't be
attracted to women you should be
attracted to anybody or any
any kind of being or in what any species
any age
like no let please let me be attracted
to who i'm attracted to
because that should be like the the
pinnacle of human freedom
yeah if you don't believe in freedom
anywhere else
you should believe in me choice freedom
it should be a fundamental human right
i think and where you get
horrible totalitarian societies really
infringing on mate choice freedom like
you're not allowed to marry that person
or you know you have to do an arranged
marriage to that person
we kind of recoil at that and go that's
horrible
and yet in america we have busy bodies
and virtue signalers um
telling us your mate choice criteria are
too
narrow so where do gay people
fit in all of this then at a biological
or an evolutionary perspective you've
brought up the point of passing on genes
many times now
gay couples or gay people whether you're
a couple or not
don't do that at least biologically
speaking
um so what what do you make of that
condition is that even the right word
now i'm gonna get i'm gonna get us both
in trouble probably just for me asking
the question
let's call it a trait trait's pretty
neutral okay all right trade's pretty
neutral
well here's the fascinating thing about
homosexuality is
people have been developing or trying to
develop theories of male homosexuality
and it's kind of evolutionary origins
and functions for
30 40 years and there is no good theory
of it yet it's a complete mystery i've
never seen any compelling
explanation of male homosexuality
so what would be a compelling a
compelling argument would be
okay there's costs of being
like exclusively attracted to your own
sex and therefore not
typically having as many kids but
there's some countervailing benefits of
some sort
maybe benefits to your extended family
or benefits to your group
or something else but nobody can make
the math
work enough to kind of explain that
female bisexuality is much easier right
you can go well
as long as a woman is sometimes
attracted to men
enough to have kids then also being
attracted to women it might be
no cost at all or it might even be a
benefit in terms of social networking
and making friends sex is a great way to
make friends
if a lot more males were bisexual
that would be equally easy to explain
um it's the exclusive homosexuality
that's very hard to explain
it certainly exists it exists at a
you know a percentage that's much much
higher than
you can explain is just well it's just
mutations or it's just maladaptive
like that won't work so
this is where i'll be kind of
epistemically humble and say man i have
no idea
it's an it's a fascinating problem maybe
somebody will crack it
within 10 or 20 years right it's
interesting because if you were coming
at it from another perspective
like a religious perspective let's say
you would find that to be
a moral quandary that then you could
extrapolate
all sorts of different judgments on yeah
but i can see the way you answer it it's
like
just is a thing maybe we'll get more
data on it
but it is but what do you make of the
fact that there are seemingly many more
bisexual
women where i don't know any gay couple
that one of the guys is sneaking out at
night to bang a woman you know i mean
i've never heard of that but you have
heard of obviously straight couples
where the guy is
you know on the dl or whatever yeah yeah
well my girlfriend dianna fleischman has
a whole theory of female bisexuality
that's
that's to do with the the social
networking benefits
um but then the question is yeah why
don't the men do that too
because like if if you're a guy and you
kind of swing both ways then
like doing gay sex can be a great way to
make male friends
also and it's well now i know we have
our uh
our promo for the show
and so in a way the quandary isn't why
do any
male homosexuals exist the quandary is
why aren't
all males and females bisexual
and do you think some of that years from
now we might look back and go whoa
that's just societal pressure
it might be i think certainly there's a
huge amount of stigma against male
bisexuals
from both sexes but especially women
female bisexuality used to be
stigmatized maybe 30 years ago not so
much anymore
yeah so it that could change
what are some of the other topics that
are that are really on your mind these
days
let's hit up effective altruism yeah
let's talk about that
um i don't know if you've had many
guests on talking about
the fact of altruism but it's not a ton
actually
it's sort of my hot topic of the last
few years so
it's a social movement a moral movement
it's some of the smartest young people
i've ever met
and their basic goal in life is do the
most
good they can based on reason and
evidence rather than sentimentality and
virtue signaling
i've done a little bit of this sort of
in an ancillary way with some of the
libertarians that i've yeah
yeah and so the kind of major domains
they tend to focus on are things like
how do we get charities to be more
effective at reducing global poverty
or promoting global public health how do
we
overcome factory farming and be nice to
animals and promote animal welfare and
so a lot of the effect of altruists are
vegan
for ethical reasons and then a lot of
them are focused on
just survival of the species how do we
reduce
existential risks to humanity like
nuclear war bio weapons
and artificial intelligence risks
so maybe the most distinctive thing they
have is this kind of ultra long-term
perspective
that's like we are just these transient
little beings
the thing that really matters is
what does humanity turn into how long do
we last
do we colonize the universe or do we
fail
and folks who think most seriously about
that
think it's actually that lasting
minimizing existential risk that is
absolutely crucial and everything else
is just kind of fluff and [ __ ]
so is this where like the transhumanist
crew would sort of fit within this
is there is so i love this stuff because
i'm a sci-fi
guy i mentioned philip k dick before i
mean every one of his stories or books
are about the inevitability of all of
these things is there a risk though of
always looking at
what's beyond the horizon instead of
going on right now
i don't really think there's a risk
unless like the vast majority of humans
became effective altruists
there's already so many people who are
obsessed with
um you know diversity and equity and
inclusion
and economic growth and
all the ordinary problems that
politicians talk about
that that's covered there's already a
lot of smart people working on that
the the big neglected topics tend to be
the kind of science fictiony topics
where you need a sort of cadre of
genius aspies right to work on it
when nobody else is taking it seriously
yeah
well speaking of the aspects that's an
interesting one if we wanted to get into
one that's a little
a little controversial as well um
what what is that all about that so many
of the creators now
or the people that are coming out of the
tech world even though
you can obviously make plenty of
arguments that the tech world is now in
a sort of implosion and certainly not
the creative place it was
yeah say 10 years ago but that so much
creativity came out of a world that had
so many people that were seemingly
uncreative
i think it's fascinating um i sort of
identify
as moderately aspie myself kind of
high-functioning aspergers
and i've written some stuff about how
neurodiversity issues like being asked
be kind of rub up against free speech
issues because like can you explain that
people who are aspy don't always do a
good job of
understanding the beliefs and desires of
other people and particularly what they
might find offensive
right so they might just say something
so they might just say
[ __ ] and then be really surprised that
it was distressing to someone
and so if you have a model of speech
that says
you must never cause offense
that assumes you can anticipate what
will cause offense
and a lot of people can't anticipate
that because
their brains don't work that way so
you either need to say okay aspies
you can never say anything
or cut them some slack and say
we understand you'll offend people once
in a while but that's okay because
that's you
just that's part of your deal man i've
never thought about this but does this
somehow explain what's going on in
silicon valley
right now you have a bunch of people who
are somewhat socially awkward let's say
who created incredible technology that
allowed us to all connect
but then when voices that aren't
supposed to aren't supposed to that's a
horrible way framing
when voices that are a little out there
or a little contrarian or whatever that
might include us actually
get out there the only way they can deal
with it is to shut that voice off or
something like that like
which is why we're seeing so much
de-platforming and silencing right they
have to be overly systematizing about it
they have to be like oh man i can't i
can't navigate these gray areas
if i'm running a social media platform
or patreon or whatever right so
i'm gonna just have a hard and fast rule
that says
if i get enough complaints i d-platform
that person
or um
i don't know the difference between porn
and erotica and just
slightly sexy art so i'm going to say no
nipples
whatever that's a kind of aspy response
to getting blow back
from people where you like you don't
really know why they're upset
so in a weird way if you have a bunch of
the creators of silicon valley that
are coming from that world and then you
suddenly bring in
a bunch of executives that come from the
social justice world
that really shows like uh that's a match
made in hell right it's just matter
antimatter
yeah it's um it's terrible
and what i hoped would happen
is that maybe five or ten years ago it
seemed like
hot like tech is dominating culture
generally and tech is dominated by
aspies
so hopefully aspie values
of being kind of tolerant and eccentric
and nerdy and
like getting weird little enthusiasms
that that would kind of trickle down
[Music]
and create a more tolerant culture is
that what you would have predicted say
10 years ago yeah
really and instead you have the opposite
you have the the social justice
activists
taking over and basically saying
all of that quirky freedom that you you
ask me people
value we're gonna legislate that
away you you can't have that
um and it's it's tragic
i hope the pendulum swing swings back
but
um as long as the leaders of the social
media platforms don't have the guts
to say look
this is our people outspoken
eccentric slightly socially oblivious
people
and that's okay and the rest of you just
have to kind of
suck it up and deal with it that's what
they should be doing yeah
it's interesting i'm at the point with
all this and you know how frustrated
i've been
with youtube and twitter and patreon and
the whole thing i'm really at the point
of this where i actually believe that
that
solution is gone i don't think it can
come from the top anymore i
really don't believe that i think that
thing has become so corroded
that i would say the only way it can
come is now from the bottom
and then the people will basically rise
up against these things and i know
that's like
it's sort of pie in the sky because what
does that even mean do we all sign off
on the same day do we all
you know whatever that means but i
almost see that as the only way to do
this because they've had we've done
everything else
or the government will get involved and
that certainly rings all the bells that
i'm not happy with on my libertarian
side
yeah i i i think at least in terms of
universities the only solution to
some of the university problems is the
government actually
saying at least to the public
universities that are in principle bound
by the constitution
you guys have to obey the first
amendment yeah or
you lose federal funding i think that's
the only leverage
yeah and i was really kind of hoping
that potus would do that
at some point in the last year or two
i'm pretty disappointed that he hasn't
well in a weird way he almost benefits
the more that they go against it right
because that feeds his base of yeah
aggrieved and politically correct
yeah you know that they see political
correctness running amok yeah something
like that
um all right before we finish up give me
give me one thing we're at the beginning
of 2019 right now
give me one thing that we should be sort
of thinking about
that we're not thinking about right now
i love the thought experiment of like
once elon musk succeeds and we start
colonizing mars
what what are the relationships and
social structures
and the mars colonies going to look like
i'm fascinated by this
this issue like yeah are the colonies
going to be
like
[Music]
communist utopias are they going to be
libertarian
um aspirational states are they
is everyone going to do monogamous
lifelong marriage is it going to be
crazy polyamorous kinky stuff
i think it's great to think about this
stuff before we
attempt it and i think mars is going to
be this amazing experiment
where like this colony gets formed based
on these social and sexual assumptions
and this one gets formed and this one
fails
catastrophically or or it like
it doesn't work well enough and it just
borrows the organization of this other
place
so i think it'll be this incredible kind
of behavioral science laboratory
and i can't wait to say that's not too
far from the way the america was set up
right that the states were supposed to
be
those places of experiment yeah um
it's yeah it's the way the east coast
was 200 250 years ago and i think
um the difference now is
the colonies will be able to communicate
with each other and with us
and be able to measure a bunch of
outcomes and deliberately experiment
and i think we need to kind of get out
ahead of that
and start like rereading all of our
classic science fiction and figuring out
how is this going to apply for reals now
now that we do it yeah which is so
related to why you think art is
important
because fiction's just as important i
mean you realize it all ends with that
eventually they figure it out
they have their tea party and then we
blow them up like yeah
but they do beautiful art nouveau like
domes in the meanwhile yeah jeffrey i'm
so glad we finally did this yeah
and let's do it again for sure and if
you want to see a good combination
of bright smart thought and snark on
twitter
follow jeffrey at primalpoly